some of our favorite lines and animated
films are actually happy accidents you'd
be surprised by how many iconic scenes
were improvised by actors in the
recording booth we've got 15 of our
favorite improvised moments and animated
films coming right up we know exactly
what to do
number one
we're gonna talk about bruno how could
we not discuss his brilliant ad-lib that
brought a rat telenovela to the film
that love could never be
john louisamo was given the chance by
directors byron howard and jared bush to
improvise a bit in the booth and thank
goodness he did this was just one of his
additions throughout his performance
there are different shades of the actor
that come through it may be small but
it's also comic genius number two
luisa was having a bit of a meltdown
the strong lisa wasn't feeling so hot
and jessica darrow brought all the agony
she could into the booth to capture the
true drama and spirit of the moment the
team had the actress improvising some
sounds of agony and cries the actress
was pretty into it so she asked if she
could take it a step further and throw
in some actual dialogue and then this
happened
yeah it was a heartbreaker but the
production team knew it was perfect in
the context of the story this improv
line even caught the louisa actress off
guard she had no idea it was going to be
part of the film until she was watching
the final cut herself number three
not all improv is funny one of the most
touching moments in riot and the last
dragon is when raya takes a moment to
herself to pray
if i can be honest and a whole lot of it
was dialogue coming straight from actor
kelly marie tran she explained i
remember asking if i could try something
different because i remember what it
felt like to be desperate and i remember
how i acted in those moments and what it
felt like to pray to a being in this
case ray is praying to see sue that
you're not even sure exists you're just
that desperate
number four
if we have time for a few more jokes
she'll tell him aquafina is a jokester
in her own life so whenever she came
across a joke written in the script the
actor would ask
let me try just a few more what were
they gonna say no well we still have a
big chunk of it since the part was
written with her voice in mind it only
made sense
number five
this could probably be considered a
special skill if you need someone who
can belch on command luca actor jacob
tremblay is your guy
[Music]
when the luca team was recording and
they came to the part in script where
luca was meant to let out a burp
tremblay figured he'd offer his services
i was able to give them some cool sound
bites and they ended up using my burp in
the film trombley loved the experience
of improvising especially with the
encouragement of his director enrico
casarosa who let me bring a lot of that
into the experience
number six if it's good you find a way
to make it work sacha baron cohen's ugo
wasn't even a character at first so he
didn't end up being part of too many
scenes but then the team got a whole lot
of great content from the actor in the
booth some people think i'm mad to live
in the deep for director casa rosa it
was a pleasure to see cohen came in and
he improvised so much that we even put a
little button at the end of our movie to
contain more of the improvisation that
he did for us because he was so fun if
it works you better work it i think that
they are the ones who are mad not me the
one who is mad it's there
number seven
it's a fight sure but it's a hilarious
fight when barney and ron find
themselves on the run from the bubble
company they get into a bit of a scuffle
have you got water damage to the brain i
mean seriously but it was all zach
galifianakis and jack dylan grazer the
performers actually had a special
session together in the recording booth
just to improvise the fight their improv
was riddled with comedy gold so instead
of sticking with what was planned the
animators literally just took their
dialogue and made the animation fit what
they said it was too good not to use it
was a wild experience for sure the wrong
actor explaining it's weird because you
don't know the person
just like with anything else you're
working on you have to act like you know
them since they weren't meant to be long
time pals in the movie anyway it
definitely helped bring some
authenticity to the film
number eight
lina was bringing herself to this film
it's a short and quick line but this
my girlfriend's daughter got me pulling
my hair out okay is in fact not what was
originally in the script when the
spectre actor was recording she swapped
the word husband for girlfriend just
wanting to be her authentic self in that
moment the team was caught off guard but
they were all for it
it's not easy being a new parent number
nine
say hello to a dream team it was magical
it was magical he and peel have a pretty
special relationship and they brought
all those good vibes to the table when
they were recording their lines for toy
story 4. you got a kid like like a kid
kid like a human kid one very special
moment is the five or so seconds of an
original wrap that's heard in the film
for these two it just made sense we sing
to each other and so it was something
that came up in the creating of the
characters within the story that's just
a taste of the improv the duo actually
sang three songs and the team recorded
three minutes worth but in the end we
only got five seconds we'll just be here
waiting for the full album release
number 10
the actor himself didn't know this would
be included josh gad was maybe the most
surprised to find out just how much of
his improv made it to the frozen films
i don't
even know it's samantha the scene
leading up to his big number when i am
older in frozen two was one of the best
bits he brought to the film gad
explained it never ceases to amaze me
that i'm allowed to improv something
clinically insane in a sound booth and
then the best animators in the world
take my nonsense and bring it to life
over thousands of hours considering how
good it is we're not surprised
number 11.
his name is olaf and guess what and i
like warm hugs this might just be the
most adorable improvised line there is
god explained improv has been such an
essential part of my journey in creating
olaf that came from jen and chris saying
this character represented youth and
naivete
and those two worlds allowed me to just
explore and find these non-sequiturs
that made the characters spark
number twelve
when it comes to dragon training improv
is a must jay barachel was free to do
his thing in the how to train your
dragon recording booth and had some
excellent improv included in the final
cut like this shady insult thank you for
nothing new useless reptile and of
course some of hiccup's grim vibes
we're dead
[Music]
number 13. with this actor in the booth
improv is hard to avoid all hail kristen
wiig an improv genius who according to
the team was able to make anything sound
funny and maybe most importantly willing
to take anything to the most ridiculous
degree her improv was scattered
throughout the how to train your dragon
recording sessions but one of the best
scenes that was full of wigs spontaneous
lines and moments saw her annoying the
heck out of grimmel as possibly the most
annoying prisoner he'd ever dealt with
number 14
it was subtle but it spoke volumes in
the original script gobber was meant to
tell hiccup about why velka and stoic
were so tense with each other and
explaining that's the reason why he
didn't get married but what he wasn't
meant to say was
this and one other reason
after craig ferguson was the one
responsible for adding that small detail
and director dean debloa felt they
should include it because in his own
words i think it's nice it's progressive
it's honest and it feels good so we
wanted to keep it
number 15
use what you know elizabeth tobicky was
maybe a bit too good at this the actress
was improvising like a master in the
booth for peta rabbit too but then
director will gluck reigned on her
parade saying she was probably just
drawing on my own personal experience of
being an incredibly bossy big sister i
have two siblings and i'm so bossy and
will probably had to be like could you
just be a little less it's a children's
film and to think this was just a taste
of the feistiness she brought the
freedom to record and re-record in the
booth means more fantastic material to
bring to the table and we are here for
it which scene on our list was your
favorite